ganz deutschland führt immer noch eine
sehr sehr aufgeregte debatte und zwar
über den wolf letzte woche schon wieder
im bundestag ich weiß kann ich das
wievielte mal die afg verlangt eine
totalüberwachung also so eine art wolf
stasi obwohl keine andere tierart so
genau beobachtet wird wie die gerade
einmal 73 rudel die durch deutschland
streifen
die fdp möchte den wolf ins jagdrecht
überführen also letztlich erschießen und
die cdu meint der nicht mit ihnen leben
muss sagt süß wer mit ihm leben muss hat
angst und da redet sie nur von ihrer
familie spaß zumindest bislang ist kein
einziger mensch verletzt worden werwolf
es eine der bedrohtesten tierarten
europa ist es fakt also einfach mal
versachlichen die debatte sowie die afd
die neuerdings ihr herz für schäfer
entdeckt hat wenn er am morgen auf die
weide kommt und er mehrere seiner schafe
gerade noch lebendig mit ausgerissenen
bäuchen heraus quellen den gedärmen oder
angefressenen hinterläufen vorfindet ja
nicht schön aber dass wölfe nicht mit
messer und gabel essen ist eigentlich
bekannt
und der größte feind des ländchens ist
immer noch ostern freunde
abgesehen davon der herdenschutz zum
beispiel durch elektrozäune wird von den
bundesländern fast komplett bezahlt wie
gesagt einfach mal versachlichen ängste
ernst nehmen aber versachlichen
so wie die bild -zeitung hier alles aus
den letzten tagen was hat man da wolfs
angst ganze seite oder jetzt weint der
böse wolf hat meine lieblings schafe
gefressen und wirklich die krönung wolf
reist 3 therapie schafe in
seniorenheimen
ja gut ich sage mal besser als drei
senioren im schafstall jetzt also nur
zum vergleich
doch wirklich
fast jeden tag solche horror
schlagzeilen und kurz danach schreibt
die selbe bild das hier unbekannte töten
immer mehr wölfe die blutspur der
wolfstädter woher kommt die wut auf
wölfe es ist wirklich ein rätsel meine
damen und herren total hysterische
debatte von vielen stadtbewohnern wird
der wolf umgekehrt ja auch total
romantisiert was quatsch ist auf dem
land sieht man das alles viel
pragmatischer
da werden wölfe zum beispiel mit eseln
bekämpft was wir treten nicht nur mit
den hinterbeinen sondern einen esel
schritt auch nach vorne
ein esel würde auch zur seite treten
aber sie würden dem wolf auch ins genick
weißen oder da wo sind gerade kriegen
und tod schütteln und dann auf den boden
werfen und dann nochmal drauf treten
[Musik]
das ist die antwort das ist
sechsmal
hier sehen sie die lösung gewaltbereite
hooligans quasi die hälse logge mich
warum nicht wolfs angst wirkt das es
fakt wolfgang wird sie bringt die bei
bild die klickzahlen nach oben und bei
der afg die umfragen im wolfs land
brandenburg wo im herbst gewählt wird
steht die alternative für deutschland
gerade bei rund 20 wir schalten mal
leicht ins brandenburgische lenin zu
matthias matschke afb landtagskandidat
und hobbyjäger herr matschke geht diese
ganze wolfs panikmache nicht doch ein
bisschen weit
denn das ist noch mal so ein zwei süße
problem das er bei sich zu hause wohnen
im gästeklo von dem zwölf zwar läuft in
berlin-mitte dass sie sich von meinen
gez-gebühr gekauft haben zusammen mit
ihrer frau aisha aber sagen sie mir
nicht weh dich erschießen da und du dich
natürlich größer die debatte
versachlichen
mario auch ja mein neues wahlplakat das
böse hat einige sich selbst schließen
jetzt die sind so schwer zu treffen weil
jeder so klein sind die biester ist
übungssache h herr manches schon jetzt
dürfen doch so genannte problem wölfe
also wölfe die sich auffällig verhalten
geschossen werden
ich will aber auch unauffällige wölfe ab
kleinwort abnormer und meine partei
steht da nicht alleine
lisa fdp kollege hat völlig recht wenn
er sagt wir wollen ja nicht abschaffen
wir wollen in regulieren genau wie jede
andere tierart und da geht es um die und
pathologe population da geht's unsere
ja dort gibt uns droht dieses
unkontrollierte wolkig der dreck nicht
und darauf haben ständig text und ich
kann mir nur noch super grenze für wölfe
feierabend ja das ist doch mein eindruck
für euren angst wahlkampf ist der wolf
jetzt quasi der neue flüchtlinge
natürlich was sollen wir denn machen
es kommen ja kommen noch flüchtlinge
nach brandenburg weil war es beim
rätseln ja
wir leben vielleicht noch drei bis fünf
flüchtlings rudel
damit kann man nicht arbeiten aber sagen
sie mal brandenburg hat doch ganz andere
sorgen schlechte straßen ärztemangel und
ein drittel des landes hat nicht mal
internet ja warum denn wohl
wir hatten die ganzen glasfaser kabel
durchgebissen war nicht vielleicht
eichhörnchen ich meine neuen haben sie
selber denn schon mal irgendwas
bedrohlich ist erlebt mit wölfen weil
ich die tricks kennen wenn sie auf dem
land leben denn gibt so kleine
strategien im umgang mit wildtieren lauf
war in den wald damit ich sehen können
ob da wölfe sind gehe bitte helga weiter
auf dem tier zu kurz wir sind ob das ein
problem ist matthias maucksch gemacht
haben und herren für weitere videos
klickt unten und abonniert auch unseren
channel alles im kasten
ok
[Musik]
wo geht's denn hier raus
scheiße